this is one of the many bunkers that is
working in kiev these were set up a long
time ago but they're sort of being put
back into rotation this one was opened
up in
1971. i'm told it can hold about 210
people and over here this is actually a
map of the facility to give you an idea
of the number of rooms that are here
it's not a big space but it is
functional and has an air vent system
that does not pull in air from outside
but ventilates it throughout the
building here that can be done manually
or by electricity if we go over here
like i said this is a very old shelter
it's been used hasn't been used in a
long time some of these posters talk
about what to do in a case of an
emergency medical attention that can be
administered there's also a little
medical room in this bunker there's what
to do in a case of
a nuclear attack a biological attack
these posters were actually added to
this bunker after chernobyl again no
one's thinking that these will
necessarily be needed but should they be
needed they are here for people in kiev